[Music]
what up kids
it's cole this is erl i've traveled all
over the world
looking for the wildest experiences to
entertain you guys
you watched commented and told me what
to do next i challenge all of you to
find something that scares me i dare you
come on
we are taking you to an escape room
experience in moscow
i have a buddy named alexi he wants to
take us everywhere
i'm talking the best clubs the best
restaurant this guy's so rich that
everything he does
is the best i've been to escape rooms
man but not one like this because to
make it just for you you have to be
invited
look i get that there are two sides of
you there's this public hole
and there's this private cool i just
don't really know the real you
remember as real as everything might
seem
you're safe sketchy at all
it will begin streaming it directly into
your device from the cameras let's do it
this is crazy
what's going on
what happened here what the hell is this
this is your guy you was just talking
about i don't know him all that well
what
we were in russia with some guy that you
barely know are you crazy
we don't have our phones our wallets
passports anything we need to leave
they change it every single time it's
intense but it's a game
i couldn't say nothing earlier because
he is always watching
hello cole how do you know my name
is young americans
you think yeah what if this is still
part of it no we lost look at the timer
please let her go why the chest is a
little more selective than yours
[Music]
oh yo delete that last part no dude this
is live
[Music]
you